la iglesia la alta gira era considerada
una de las más importantes y bonitas de
oriente ese es el estado que quedó
después de 2014 cuando dices declaró a
mosúl como capital de su califato
voy a hacer lideró un proyecto de
jóvenes arquitectos e informáticos que
reconstruyen en tercera dimensión esta
iglesia y otros monumentos insignes de
mosúl cáncer
el proyecto se basa en fotografiar cada
detalle aquí en la iglesia tanto con
cámara como tomas aéreas así que usamos
drones para cubrirlo desde el cielo
el resultado final son estos prototipos
virtuales que están disponibles en
internet y que permiten descubrir por
qué hemos un siempre fue una las
ciudades más importantes de oriente
medio
este trabajo de digitalizar las imágenes
es responsabilidad de este estudiante de
arquitectura que tenía 16 años cuando y
cesc llegó a la ciudad
fue muy duro quedarse en la ciudad y ver
gente matar a otra gente
porque la infección
y muchos otros jóvenes que fueron
testigos ya que el infierno que trajo y
sésamo sur se han volcado a trabajar
para recuperar el alma de la ciudad he
decidido quedarme porque mosúl me
necesita como ingeniera civil y como
persona y nace parte de un proyecto de
la unesco que recupera las casas del
centro histórico puesto que todavía no
hemos superado todos los obstáculos que
hemos confrontado después de la
liberación de estos murales tratan de
darle otro espíritu a la ciudad vieja
los responsables son un colectivo
conocido como arte revolución es muy
interesante cuando los niños vienen y
nos preguntan qué hace este hombre viejo
y si es dejó una herida muy profunda
mosúl que posiblemente tardé años en
sanar pero estos jóvenes están
dispuestos a no dejarse robar su derecho
a luchar por el renacimiento de su
ciudad